The first question you'll probably ask yourself at this
point. How do I access App Engine in the
first place? Well that is a pretty important question
to answer. And we're happy to tell you that it's
super easy. So first of all, here you are.
A star developer. And you should already have a
Google account, that you probably use for many different
Google services. Such as Gmail, YouTube, Google Plus, et cetera.
Well, guess what? Your standard Google account also allows you
to create app engine applications that run on the Google
cloud platform. So there is no additional account required. What
you do is simply log on to the developers console
that we will go through later. And register the App
Engine applications you want to create. And once you've done
that, the time has come for you to create those
great cloud applications. So you need to sit down, and
hack, and hack. And hack, and hack until you
have something awesome that you want to test. And then
you can fire up an instance of App Engine, which
runs on your local development machine. And that is of
course, great. Since it allows you to use all your
standard tools. Such as debuggers and providers to get those
bugs out. And once you've done that, it's time to
run your applications on computers in the Google data centers.
So, with just a click or two, you can
deploy all of that great code to App Engine. And
of course, you can have many applications running there. And
when you and your front-end developer friend have finished your
application. You tell all your users about how cool
it is, and that they can start using it. And
when you use App Engine, it's very easy to support
any kind of device and operating system. Computers, smartphones, tablet's.
You name it. And hopefully, the users will think
your application is so cool, that they will tell their
friends about how cool it is. And hopefully they will
tell their friends. And your application goes all viral. And
you get all of these great ratings and recognitions. And
awards and stuff. But you don't need to worry about
your site going down because it has become so popular,
since you built it on the Google cloud. It will
scale and scale, and scale on the Google infrastructure.
So you get to feel like a million bucks. And
become a rock start developer that everyone wants to be
with. This is exactly what we would like to happen.
And that's really what this is all about. App Engine
and Google cloud platform, allows you to create applications that
run in Google data centers. And can be used by
any device. So you can sit with your laptop and
create apps that scale to serve billions of
users worldwide. It's really, really cool when you think
about it. Well, hang in there. Because you're
just about to create your first App Engine project.